[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today okay
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey good afternoon Ken and George thank
you so much for taking my call
well I got kind of uh
a work life
balance question for you and I'm
wondering to try to get your input on it
sure
um basically I'm 43 I've worked multiple
jobs my whole life up to three jobs my
parents owned a local restaurant I
cooked that for 10 plus years and I went
to college and trade school worked in
the automotive industry and when I
graduated from high school I actually
started and I currently owned and
operate my own mobile DJ service so I
worked three jobs gone seven days a week
um me and my wife when we we got married
we were high school sweethearts we got
married we made the joint decision that
she would be home and to raise our three
boys which she had done and did a great
job with
well now uh like I said we're both 43
now she wants me home a little bit more
and I'm finding myself struggling you
know to try to find
um
mentally and adjust myself to to not
work as hard or work as much as what I
was doing
um like I said we both own our own
businesses
she works part-time she pretty much
picks her own hours
um I'm gone pretty much all the weekends
43 weekends a year
um
why can't you hire some some young blood
to go out there and travel for you
well that's the problem I do I do have I
do have another crew that goes with me
to me it's not work it's a passion I
love it okay so hold on seven days a
week so so are you still working three
jobs or just the one mobile DJ on the
weekends and the 40-hour job during the
week
yep yep I'm a sales rep for a company
okay in the Chicago area yep so what
kind of money are you making as a mobile
DJ how close to matching or uh
uh over overcoming your current day job
over I make more than what I do at my
full-time job I make roughly 105 000 a
year DJing I think about 93 with my
sales job so you just begs the question
why aren't you knocking the uh the uh 40
hour a week job off and more time with
Mama and doing what you love on the
weekends
well health insurance that's the biggest
one health insurance and I I I it's bad
and my wife she says it too I'm
I'm greedy you know why not make the
money while I can You're Gonna Lose Your
what you want to lose your wife and
you're gonna lose your wife over this
no I right and that's what she says to
me she's like you know not too many
wives would uh want their husbands gone
as as much as you are but
I have not missed out on any of our
family functions we do have stuff the
oldest is going to college EJ
your wife wants you to slow down
yes
she may have been agreeable
but I don't think she's going to
continue to be agreeable and this isn't
good for you and I'm going to suggest to
you that there's more to it than greed I
don't I think that's a I think that's a
cheap excuse for you as to why you're
working all the time
and I'm not trying to put you on the
spot I don't want to in any way
um uh attack you and I there's something
going on with you or you need to be busy
all the time and you've got your wife
crying out gently saying I want you here
I want us to have more time together
you've done a great job so far you got
your kids out they're doing their thing
you're financially great you've got this
passion project which is spinning off
more money than your day job and I think
there's something that you're running
from
and I think the busier you are the less
you have to listen to it
am I right or am I wrong and I don't
mind being wrong
no you're yeah you're absolutely right I
feel like I got to be doing something
all the time I just can't like sit down
and yeah but there's a reason there's a
reason for that and you're you're and
you need to you need to sit with a
counselor and a therapist and let's and
I'm not going to put you on the spot
here but I'm telling you you're like the
people who run all the time ultra
marathoners they're running from
something
yeah they just are
I'm not attacking I'm not no no listen
some people are smiling in the booth
listen I'm telling you if you're all the
time like every spare minute of your day
you're exercising or running it's
because you're trying to stay ahead of
something as opposed to meeting it head
on and you've admitted this and your
wife is crying out for you and you
better listen and I'm just going to tell
you you need to figure out why you want
to be working all the time because
that's not natural which means it's not
healthy
right nope you're absolutely right 100
right so TJ there's a few options here
number one you drop the DJ stuff you
choose the local gig spare and drop the
DJ he loves that he loves it but what if
he could do the local ones and hire the
team out and he still makes some money
off of that he can still choose yeah or
you leave this full-time job you just DJ
and that's what you do in your home all
week with your wife and you're gone on
the weekends get healthy but we can't
continue doing all of this multiple jobs
never at home and your wife wondering
did I sign up to be single because the
kids are gone now she's really feeling
what she said dude that's a word for
word of what exactly she said now we
only have one of our of our sons is in
college and we're casual in that so he's
going to college debt free and we have
two other Sons one's a junior in high
school and the other is in eighth grade
so we do have almost even more but it's
even more important that you're in the
home I misunderstood I thought all three
were gone now it's even double important
that you're there and don't get and
don't play the whole I'm at all their
sporting events doesn't matter if you're
not around the house and you're not
there you're setting a precedent and an
example for your boys that it's okay to
be checked out as long as you say you're
working or you're busy and that couldn't
be further from the truth
and I listen I know that sounds tough
it's not my heart's hurting for you and
your wife I'm glad you admitted it I
want you to go see accounts I'm going to
challenge you you need to be in a couple
therapy sessions before 30 days is up
and begin to dive in deep as to what's
got you running so fast
what are you running from
healing health
everything's on the other side of that